mauro colagreco déjà étoilé au michelin
poursuit son ascension fulgurante aux
commandes du mirazur qu'il a rachetée il
y a trois ans vanessa caupenne filles et
pourrait dans le jardin d'agrumes en
restanques au pied de son restaurant de
menton mahoro colagreco fait sa
cueillette quotidienne ça c'est la fleur
de si vous l'êtes chinoise alors ça on
utilise et il ya un parfum très high et
c'est très proche à l'ail et on utilise
pour l'un
pl que c'est havas des tomates cet
amoureux du végétal cultive ses propres
fleurs ces herbes aromatiques et ses
légumes rares je crois que c'est une
chance énorme pouvoir avoir un peu de
terrain pour l'avoir ccp l'observent
sais c'est parfum c'est un peu comme son
vivier les parfums du jardin ces trésors
de la nature maroco l'agricole et
décline dans une cuisine inventive et
délicates ou le légume est roi ça marche
de couverts de cartes avec un poêle à
alomar ou sur al ahly or un pigeon une
cuisine inspirée de l'argentine et de
l'italie les pays de ses racines enrichi
de ses passages chez les plus grands
l'oiseau passard ou du casque déjà
étoilé au michelin
cette nouvelle distinction layton il
faut le mettre sur l'os c'est parce que
c'était une blague et faire rêver les
pieds en appelant une personne que je
connaissais
voir s'ils pouvaient se renseigner que
finalement ce n'était pas une blague
1 c'est une responsabilité
c'est un peu plus encore de pression
parce que il faut
il faut montrer qu'ils ont les
médicaments c'est aussi une très bonne
publicité pour un jeune établissement
repris il ya trois ans seulement dans
une ville plus réputée pour ses citrons
que pour ses restaurants
c'est difficile de faire venir les gens
jusqu'à nous parce qu'on est quand même
assez éloignées ça permet de
reconnaissance donc après la mise en
lumière une reconnaissance de la cuisine
du travail effectué et puis ça permet
surtout
à la possibilité de continuer à avancer
parce que sans client malheureusement
pas d'argent l'arrêt et économique est
là et sans argent les portes se ferment
le raid des portes qui seront pourtant
clause jusqu'en février prochain avant
de recevoir cette distinction
le chef avait déjà prévu de faire mouche
pour la saison d'hiver
[Musique]